BUT FIRST, THE MASKS ARE OFF.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK TO THE ROSE
GARDEN TODAY, AND WHAT DID HE
DO?
HE ANNOUNCED HIS NEW VACCINE
TASK FORCE.
HE SET THE BAR HIGH WITH AN
AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE, BUT HE GAVE
AMERICA, AT THE SAME TIME, JUST
WHAT SHE NEEDED: OPTIMISM FOR
OPENING.
>> WE HAVE THE BEST AND MOST
DEVOTED WORKERS EVER TO WALK THE
FACE OF THE EARTH, AND NOW WE
ARE COMBINING ALL OF THESE
AMAZING STRENGTHS FOR THE MOST
AGGRESSIVE VACCINE PROJECT IN
HISTORY, AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SOMETHING CLEAR.
IT’S VERY IMPORTANT.
VACCINE OR NO VACCINE, WE ARE
BACK, AND WE ARE STARTING THE
PROCESS.
>> Laura: I WAS DOING THE FIST
PUMP RIGHT THERE.
YES.
DEMOCRATS, ON THE OTHER HAND,
THEY PREFER US TO COWER AND
CROUCH IN OUTHOUSES.
THEY ARE PUSHING -- PANIC PORN.
THEY SAY WE NEED MULTIPLE
VACCINES, NOT JUST ONE, AND EVEN
IF WE HAVE THEM COME WE DON’T
HOW EFFECTIVE THEY WILL BE.
THEY SAY WE NEED AS MANY AS
300,000 GOVERNMENT PAID TRACERS
AND HACKERS, HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF TESTS, ALL OF THAT
BEFORE WE CAN OPEN AGAIN.
AND A PURPLE UNICORN ON EVERY
STREET CORNER.
THE BASIC POINT HERE IS
DEMOCRATS JUST DON’T TRUST YOU,
AND FRANKLY, THEY DON’T EVEN
LIKE YOU, SO OF COURSE THEY WANT
YOU TO STAY INDOORS, OFF THE
STREETS, AND EVEN OUT OF OUT OF
YOUR CHURCHES.
WITH ONLY A FEW EXCEPTIONS, BLUE
STATE GOVERNORS ALL FAVOR
LOCKDOWNS OVER LIBERTY.
ONE OF THE ABSOLUTE WORST IS
MICHIGAN’S GRETCHEN WHITMER.
>> CERTAINLY NOT AN EXERCISE OF
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES, WHERE WE
HAVE FREE SPEECH.
THIS IS CALLS TO VIOLENCE, WITH
THE RACIST AND MISOGYNISTIC --
THESE PROTESTS, YOU KNOW, IN A
PERVERSE WAY, MAKE IT LIKELIER
THAT WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
STAY IN A STAY HOME POSTURE.
>> Laura: YOU ARE NOT
BEHAVING.
WASHINGTON STATE’S JAY INSLEE IS
PUNISHING PEOPLE WITH ANOTHER
EXTENSION OF HIS STAY-AT-HOME
ORDER, TO THE END OF MAY NOW,
EVEN THOUGH THEY FLATTENED THE
CURVE BACK IN APRIL IN
WASHINGTON STATE.
THIS IS INSANE.
SO WHEN WILL HE GIVE UP HIS VICE
GRIP ON POWER?
>> IT’S JUST A LONG WAYS AWAY
FROM THAT.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE NUMBERS
ARE STILL SO HIGH AN HOUR VIRUS
THAT IT JUST CAN’T JUSTIFY
OPENING UP ALL OF THESE BUSINESS
RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: IT’S NOT INFECTIONS,
JAY, IT’S HOSPITALIZATIONS, AND
DEATHS, THAT’S WHAT IS THE KEY
HERE.
ILLINOIS GOVERNOR J.B.
PRITZKER’S ESCALATING HIS
THREATS AGAINST THE DISOBEDIENCE
DISOBEDIENCE.
>> BUSINESSES AND INDIVIDUAL
PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE LICENSED
BY STATE AGENCIES WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR BREACHING PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND THE
ILLINOIS STATE POLICE CAN AND
WILL TAKE ACTION.
>> Laura: OOOH, BIG THREAT FOR
A BIG MAN.
WELL, AND GAVIN NEWSOM’S
CALIFORNIA, LOCAL OFFICIALS ARE
SLAPPING ALREADY SUFFERING
BUSINESSES WITH $1,000 CITATIONS
AND THREATS FOR JAIL TIME FOR
NOT COMPLYING WITH EVERYTHING
FROM MASK WEARING TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING, THE WAY THEY ARE
HANDLING THEIR BUSINESSES,
WHETHER THE STICKERS ARE ON THE
GROUND.
L.A. COUNTY, THE MOST POPULOUS
IN THE STATE, IS EXTENDING ITS
LOCKDOWN AT LEAST ANOTHER THREE
MONTHS.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A JOKE WHEN I
FIRST HEARD IT.
MEANWHILE, THE MAYOR OF L.A., HE
IS POWER TRIPPING.
>> WE ARE STILL GETTING REPORTS
EACH DAY OF NONESSENTIAL
BUSINESSES THAT CONTINUE TO
OPERATE AS NORMAL.
THIS BEHAVIOR IS IRRESPONSIBLE
AND SELFISH.
IF WE SEE CONTINUED
NONCOMPLIANCE, THEY WILL END UP
FACING MISDEMEANOR CHARGE AND A
DWP WILL STEP IN AND SHUT OFF
THEIR WATER AND POWER.
>> Laura: AND BY THE WAY,
THESE PROHIBITIONS -- I LOVE
THAT SHUTTING OFF YOUR WATER.
[LAUGHS]
THE PROHIBITIONS, THEY AREN’T
WRITTEN IN LAW, THEY ARE DONE
THROUGH GUBERNATORIAL EDICTS.
SO AS LONG AS IT IS CALLED AN
EMERGENCY, THESE GOVERNORS THINK
THEY CAN TRAVEL ON YOUR RIGHTS
WITH IMPUNITY, AND THEY ARE
DOING THAT.
BUT LAWSUITS ARE BEING FILED,
THAT’S GOOD NEWS THIS WEEK.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NEVER PROTESTED
BEFORE IN THEIR LIVES ARE
PICKING UP LACQUERS AND
PROTESTING, EVEN WHEN THEIR
LIVELIHOODS ARE THREATENED, IF
THEY STILL HAVE JOBS, OR IF THEY
JAIL TIME.
YOU GET THE SENSE BEING OUT
THERE AND HOW AMERICANS ARE JUST
FED UP.
>> WE HAVE A DAY CARE CENTER IN
FRANKLIN COUNTY, IS NOT OPEN
HALLWAY, BARELY OPEN ENOUGH TO
KEEP US AFLOAT.
>> THESE THINGS ARE TYPICALLY A
CHOICE.
THERE IS A MEASLES OUTBREAK, AND
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK STAY
HOME.
THEY ARE MAKING THEM STAY HOME,
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
>> I THINK AMERICANS NEED TO
REALIZE THEIR FREEDOMS ARE BEING
TAKEN AWAY, AND IF THEY DON’T
STAND UP FOR THEM RIGHT NOW,
THERE WON’T BE ANY FREEDOM TO
STAND UP FOR HER.
>> Laura: BUT DO ANY OF YOU
WATCHING TONIGHT THINK THAT
PELOSI AND SCHUMER CARE ABOUT
THOSE PEOPLE?
OF COURSE THEY DON’T.
IF YOU’VE LOST YOUR JOB, IF YOUR
CHILD IS STRUGGLING WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING -- DON’T YOU
LOVE THAT PHRASE?
IF YOU ARE STRUGGLING WITH
LONELINESS OR ADDICTION OR
DEPRESSION, YOU ARE JUST
COLLATERAL DAMAGE ON THE WAY TO
THE NEW NORMAL.
>> ALL OF US ARE GOING TO BE
LIVING IN A NEW NORMAL, WHETHER
THAT MEANS WEARING A MASK,
WORKING IN SHIFTS.
>> WE ARE RETURNING TO OUR NEW
NORMAL, WITH ALL OF WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT THROUGH ALL PHASES.
>> WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS DESIGN
A NEW NORMAL.
A WAY OF LIFE TO CARRY US TO THE
OTHER SIDE.
>> Laura: THEIR IDEA OF A NEW
NORMAL, NOT SO MUCH DR. BIRX, BY
THE WAY, I’M TALKING ABOUT THE
POLITICIANS -- SHE GOT CAUGHT UP
IN THE LINGO.
IT GOES FAR BEYOND FINDING A
VACCINE OR HAND WASHING OR
COVERING YOUR SNEEZES.
THAT’S ALL FINE, THAT IS JUST
COMMON SENSE.
THE NEW NORMAL FOR THEM IS
BASICALLY EVERYTHING THAT
HILLARY RAN ON AND LOST, PLUS
SOME NEW RADICAL IDEAS FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE TO MASS AMNESTY
TO GUARANTEED INCOME AND TO A
MASSIVE WEALTH TAX.
IF THE PANDEMIC ENDS, DEMOCRATS
LOSE THEIR LEVERAGE, AND THEY
KNOW IT.
THAT IS WHY EVERY CHANCE THEY
GET, THEIR MEDIA ALLIES STOKE
THE FEARS OF A WEARY AND WORRIED
NATION.
THEY WANT YOU TO BE AFRAID.
VERY AFRAID.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU ARE AFRAID,
THEY HAVE MORE POWER, THEY HAVE
MORE AUTHORITY TO TELL YOU HOW
TO LIVE YOUR LIFE.
AND MAKE NO MISTAKE, THEY WANT
THIS TO CONTINUE INDEFINITELY.
THEY ARE PLAYING THE ONLY CAR
THEY HAVE, THE FEAR CARD.
BUT THERE ARE INCREASING SIZE IN
THESE POLLS AND ON THE STREETS
THAT IT ISN’T WORKING.
THERE IS TRAFFIC AGAIN AROUND
D.C., MARYLAND, AND VIRGINIA.
I NOTICED IT TODAY.
AND THE ALWAYS LIVELY
NEW ORLEANS, WE WILL HEAR FROM
RAYMOND IN A MOMENT, RESTAURANTS
ARE CLOSED DOWN, BUT MANY ARE
OUT AND ABOUT, MANY, HE TOLD ME,
JUST IGNORING THE MASK-CHAMBERS
OUTSIDE OF COFFEE SHOPS.
FREEDOM BRIGADES OF ORDINARY
CITIZENS ARE ACTIVATED,
ENTERPRISING AMERICANS ARE
MAKING ADJUSTMENTS AND
INNOVATING SMARTLY.
NATURALLY, NASCAR WILL BE THE
FIRST NATIONAL SPORT TO REOPEN,
ALBEIT WITHOUT FANS.
WEST VIRGINIA UNIVERSITY’S
FOOTBALL COACH, HE ANNOUNCED THE
FALL SEASON IS ON.
THE SEC BETTER FOLLOW, TALKING
TO YOU, ALABAMA.
MY FRIENDS AT CAMBRIA IN
MINNESOTA PUT OUT A VIDEO OF AN
OLD PAUL HARVEY BROADCAST TODAY
THAT REALLY SEEMED APT.
>> HISTORY I STUDIED, OURS AND
OTHERS, THE MORE CERTAIN I AM
THAT THERE IS ONE FERTILIZER
ESSENTIAL TO THE SURVIVAL OF
SAID OF CIVILIZATION, AND THAT
FERTILIZER IS SWEAT, AND I MEAN
THE KIND OF STEAMY, STREAMING, S
RUN FROM A MAN BY HARD, PHYSICAL
WORK, AND SOMEHOW THE SWEAT GETS
INTO THE SOIL OF A FARM OR
FACTORY OR CITY OR STATE OR
NATION, AND EVERYTHING
THEREABOUTS GROSS TALL AND
STRONG AND TOUGH ENOUGH TO STAND
AGAINST ANY STORM.
>> Laura: "TO STAND AGAINST
ANY STORM."
THE WORK ETHIC OF AMERICA, THE
NEED TO WORK, AND WORK HARD, OF
COURSE HE NAILED IT.
PAUL HARVEY ALWAYS DID.
AMERICANS HAVE THRIVED ON THE
IDEA THAT ALTHOUGH LIFE IS OFTEN
HARD AND CHALLENGING, YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY HAVE THE FREEDOM TO
DECIDE HOW YOU WANT TO LIVE IT.
DEMOCRATS MAY LIVE AND SHUT DOWN
NIRVANA, BUT THE EMERGING
CONSENSUS IS THIS: IF YOU WANT
TO STAY AT HOME, YOU CAN STAY AT
HOME.
BUT FOR THE REST OF US, WE’LL
MAKE OUR OWN DECISIONS,
THANK YOU.
NOW WE KNOW MORE ABOUT THIS
VIRUS, EXTREMELY LOW LETHALITY’S
OR OTHERWISE HEALTHY YOUNGER
AMERICANS, THEY DO PRETTY WELL.
SENIORS, THEY NEED SPECIAL CARE,
SINCE THE SO-CALLED EXPERTS SAY
IT WILL BE AROUND FOREVER, TIME
TO MOVE ON WITH OUR LIVES.
THE TESTING ISSUE IS JUST
ANOTHER DEMOCRAT RED HERRING,
MORE IMPOSSIBLE HOOPS TO JUMP
THROUGH.
TESTING AND TRACKING FOR THE
REST OF YOUR LIFE, SINCE THE
VIRUS WILL BE WITH US FOREVER,
JUST LIKE THE FLU, THEY SAY.
THE VIRUS HAS TAKEN MANY LIVES.
AND IT’S AWFUL.
IT’S A TRAGEDY.
IT HAS WRECKED A ONCE GREAT
ECONOMY.
BUT IT HAS ALSO SHOWN, FOR ALL
THE WORLD TO SEE, WHO THESE NEW
RADICAL DEMOCRATS REALLY ARE AND
WHAT THEY WANT.
THEIR PETTY DICTATORS WHO WANT
TO FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
AMERICA WE LOVE.